so Tucker Carlson was sitting here two
weeks ago interviewing you he's gone
what do you make of that well I'm
shocked I'm surprised he's a very good
person a very good man and very talented
as you know and he had very high ratings
so uh we're just learning about it
almost as we speak now a couple people
wrote to me and there's more to this
which we'll look at saying you know
David
if you read the expression on Trump's
face this little smirk
Trump is saying one thing
but projecting another one with the
smirk and that's Trump's reaction which
is Tucker got what was coming to him
because he said bad things about me in
those text messages it's an
interpretation I don't know you make of
it what you will